Pero resulta que el estado del cerebro por defecto
se parece más a un carro con el motor en espera que a uno estacionado.
Algunas de las cosas que creemos que decidimos hacer
son en realidad cosas para las que estamos programados
cuando se suelta los frenos.
¿Alguna vez han bromeado sobre tener el cerebro en piloto automático?
¿Adivinen qué?
Probablemente lo estaba.
¿Bien?
Y el piloto automático está en una estructura llamada cuerpo estriado.
Este detecta las condiciones emocionales y motores sensoriales
y activa el comportamiento más reciente
ejecutado bajo esas mismas condiciones.
¿Saben por qué me volví una neurocientífica?
Porque quería saber qué producía mis tics.
(Risas)
Gracias, gracias.
Había querido usarla frente a una audiencia por años.
(Aplausos)
En la universidad, estudié factores genéticos
que orquestan el cableado al cuerpo estriado durante el desarrollo.
Y sí, esa fue mi antigua placa del carro.
(Risas)
Y para que conste, no le recomiendo
a ningún estudiante de doctorado que usen su tesis como placa de carro,
a menos que estén preparados para que sus experimentos
no funcionen por 2 años.
(Risas)
Finalmente lo descubrí.
Mis experimentos exploraban cómo fallas de cableado en el cuerpo estriado
se relaciona con conductas compulsivas.
No podemos resistirnos a
aquellas conductas generadas por impulsos incómodos.
Me emocioné cuando mis ratones desarrollaron
esta conducta compulsiva,
en la que se frotaban la cara y parecía que no podían parar,
a pesar de hacerse daño.
Bien, emocionada no es la palabra adecuada,
de hecho me sentía mal por ellos.
Pensé que tenían tics, evidencia de error en el cableado del estriado.
Y eran compulsivos,
Pero luego de más pruebas, resultó
que estos ratones mostraban una aversión a interactuar
y conocer a otros ratones desconocidos.
Esto nos resultó inusual, fue inesperado.
Los resultados mostraron que el cuerpo estriado,
que está involucrado en los trastornos del espectro compulsivo,
también está involucrado, no en las relaciones sociales humanas,
sino en nuestra capacidad para relacionarnos.
Así que profundicé
en un campo llamado neurociencia social.
Es un campo interdisciplinario más nuevo
donde encontré informes que unían el cuerpo estriado
no solo con anomalías sociales en ratones,
sino también en las personas.
Resulta que la neuroquímica social en el cuerpo estriado
está relacionada con cosas que probablemente ya han oído:
como la oxitocina,
que es la hormona que hace que los abrazos se sientan cálidos y cómodos.
También implica enviar señales a los receptores opioides.
En el cerebro, hay opioides que ocurren naturalmente
que están profundamente vinculados a los procesos sociales.
Los experimentos con naloxona, que bloquea los receptores opioides,
nos muestran que tan esencial es la señalización de los receptores opioides
para la interacción social.
Cuando las personas reciben naloxona, ingrediente en Narcan,
se revierte una sobredosis de opioides para salvar vidas.
Pero cuando se le administra a personas sanas,
interfiere con su habilidad para sentirse conectados
con personas que ya conocían y que les importaban.
La falta de la unión entre los receptores y los opioides
hace que nos resulte difícil sentir los beneficios de la interacción social.
Para ser concisa,
me deshice de ciertos detalles científicos,
pero, en resumen, aquí estamos.
Los efectos de la desconexión social a través de los receptores opioides,
los efectos de las drogas adictivas
y los efectos de una neurotransmisión anormal
en los movimientos involuntarios y conductas compulsivas
convergen en el cuerpo estriado.
Y el cuerpo estriado y la señalización de opioides en él
están profundamente relacionados con la soledad.
Cuando los receptores opioides no tienen suficiente señal,
nos sentimos solos en una habitación llena de gente que queremos y que nos quiere.
Neurocientíficos sociales, como el Dr. Cacioppo en la Universidad de Chicago,
han descubierto que la soledad es muy peligrosa.
Predispone a las personas
a espectros enteros de enfermedades físicas y mentales.
Piénsenlo así: cuando están muy hambrientos,
cualquier comida sabe deliciosa, ¿no?
La soledad crea hambre en el cerebro,
lo que neuroquímicamente, hipersensibiliza nuestro sistema de recompensa.
El aislamiento social actúa a través de receptores
para que los opioides naturales y otros neurotransmisores sociales
dejen al cuerpo estriado en un estado
donde la respuesta a cosas que indiquen recompensas y placer
sea completamente extrema.
En este estado de hipersensibilidad,
nuestros cerebros indican una gran insatisfacción.
Nos ponemos inquietos e irritables y nos volvemos impulsivos.
Y ahí es cuando quiero que dejen los chocolates de Halloween
del otro lado de la habitación porque me los comeré todos.
Lo haré.
Y esto trae otra cosa que hace que la desconexión social
sea tan peligrosa.
Si no tenemos la habilidad de conectar socialmente,
estamos tan desesperados por rebalancear nuestra neuroquímica social
que buscamos cualquier forma de alivio.
Y si eso es analgésicos o heroína,
será como un misil guiado a nuestro sistema de recompensa social.
¿Nos llama la atención que hoy en día la gente se vuelva adicta tan fácilmente?
El aislamiento social,
discúlpenme,
contribuye a las recaídas.
Los estudios han demostrado que las personas que evitan las recaídas
son aquellas con relaciones sociales amplias y recíprocas
donde pueden ayudarse el uno al otro,
donde cumplen una función.
Ayudar a alguien permite conectar a las personas.
Así que,
si no tenemos la habilidad de conectarnos auténticamente,
nuestra sociedad cada vez carece más de esta habilidad
y de experimentar cosas que son trascendentales y que nos superan.
Antes la obteníamos
de un sentimiento de pertenencia en nuestras familias y comunidades.
Pero las comunidades están cambiando en todas partes.
Y la desintegración social y económica hacen que esto sea cada vez más difícil.
No soy la única que señala que
las áreas del país con mayor dificultad económica,
donde las personas sienten más desolación sobre el significado de su vida,
también son los lugares
donde más comunidades han sido afectadas por los opioides.
El aislamiento social actúa a través del sistema de recompensa del cerebro
y hace que la situación sea realmente dolorosa.
Quizás es este dolor, esta soledad,
este desaliento
lo que nos está llevando a conectar con lo que sea que podamos.
Como la comida.
Como los aparatos electrónicos.
Y para muchos, con drogas como la heroína y el fentanilo.
Conozco a alguien que tuvo una sobredosis, y que fue revivida con Narcan,
y estaba muy furiosa porque no la dejaban simplemente morir.
Piensen como se siente eso, ese estado de desesperanza.
Pero el cuerpo estriado también es una fuente de esperanza.
Porque nos da una pista de cómo traer de vuelta a las personas.
Recuerden que el cuerpo estriado es nuestro piloto automático,
dirige las conductas según hábitos,
y es posible recablear, reprogramar ese piloto automático,
pero requiere neuroplasticidad.
La neuroplasticidad es la habilidad de los cerebros
de reprogramarse
y recablearse para que podamos aprender cosas nuevas.
Quizás escucharon el clásico adagio de la plasticidad:
neuronas que se activan simultáneamente, refuerzan la sinapsis.
¿Cierto?
Necesitamos practicar conductas de conexión social
en vez de conductas compulsivas cuando estamos solos,
cuando se nos estimula a recordar nuestra droga.
Necesitamos disparos neuronales de experiencias repetidas
para que el cuerpo estriado consiga la neuroplasticidad necesaria
que le permite apagar el piloto automático del "ve a buscar heroína".
La convergencia de la neurociencia social, la adicción y
los trastornos del espectro compulsivo en el cuerpo estriado sugieren que
no se trata solo de enseñarle
al cuerpo estriado mejores respuestas a los impulsos compulsivos.
Debemos reemplazar conductas compulsivas inducidas por drogas con impulsos sociales
porque debemos rebalancear nuestro sistema de recompensa social neuroquímicamente.
Si esto no sucede,
quedaremos en un estado de ansiedad.
Sin importar qué hagamos repetidamente además de nuestra droga.
Creo que la solución a la crisis de opioides
es investigar cómo las intervenciones sociales y psicoespirituales
puede actuar como neurotecnologías en circuitos
que procesan recompensas sociales e inducidas por drogas.
Una posibilidad es crear y estudiar herramientas escalables
para que las personas se conecten
mediante un interés mutuo
en la recuperación psicoespiritual.
Estas prácticas psicoespirituales comprenden
personas juntándose por ser grandes fanáticos de una banda,
grupos de parkour que comparten experiencias de vulnerabilidad
y crecimiento personal
y cosas más convencionales como encuentros de yoga recuperativo
y reuniones que se centran en concepciones más tradicionales
de experiencias espirituales.
No importa cuál sea,
pero debe activar
todos los sistemas de neurotransmisores en el cuerpo estriado
que están involucrados en procesar la conexión social.
Las redes sociales no ayudan lo suficiente.
Las redes sociales no nos estimulan a compartir,
sino a comparar.
Es la diferencia entre tener una conversación superficial
y una conversación auténtica y profunda con contacto visual.
Y el estigma también nos separa.
Hay mucha evidencia que nos mantiene enfermos.
Y el estigma muchas veces facilita que los adictos conecten con otros adictos.
Pero los grupos de recuperación que buscan restablecer la conexión social
podrían incluir a las personas que buscan recuperarse
de un amplio grupo de enfermedades mentales.
El punto es que, cuando nos conectamos a través de algo que está roto,
nos conectamos como seres humanos.
Nos sanamos de la autodestrucción compulsiva
que fue la respuesta al dolor de la desconexión.
Al pensar en enfermedades neuropsiquiátricas como un espectro de fenómenos
que es parte de lo que nos hace humanos,
eliminamos la alteridad de las personas que luchan con la autodestrucción.
Eliminamos el estigma
entre doctores, pacientes y cuidadores.
Devolvemos la pregunta de qué significa ser normal versus estar enfermo
al espectro de la condición humana.
Y es en ese espectro donde todos podemos conectarnos
y buscar sanar juntos todas nuestras luchas humanas.
Gracias por dejarme compartir.
(Aplausos)